hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we just blew
up something for a reason I don't know
okay you're through yeah I'm here to the
mall
oh nothing I work the cones on the
captain's body oh that's right I got a
I'm I'm trying to find the dead guy of
course
dammit oh I do not like the morgue you
do not like whoa this is senior medical
officer in a car and a bishop white or
blue more help we don't have the
resources to deal with this many cases
yeah nobody would tell us what's
happening these wounds we are not
equipped to deal with it
it's okay hold him hold him down yeah
you tell him what okay that was Nicole
right yeah I can't tell from here when
that log was made mm-hmm I'm sure she's
around here somewhere
yeah she's probably dead probably
if things go as I predict and nothing
goes right in this game she's probably
dead everyone that I came here was his
gonna die once probably already dead
[ __ ] this [ __ ] hey don't be so rude
children are watching
ma stop yeah I didn't have to shoot down
what was that sorry we are full what's
going on okay this doesn't look aah aah
stop jump scaring me
get out here hi No okay I'm guessing
those are your o2 shots
ah god damn it get out of here
no and no I'll get up don't get out
again
okay those are like your limbs your
those are the babies equivalent of a
limb oh those are loud oh man
okay what's that line Rex line racks has
a line rack probably ammo to a gun that
I don't some energy thing I don't know I
don't know where's this go
I know how this work there it is cuz why
aren't these things what are these
things are these just batteries and why
if their batteries did they just shut
out through the wall I do not get this
ship I don't get it I don't get it
oxygen recharge are they gonna take away
my oxygen probably probably okay
all right where am I going where am I
going where I'm going what am i what am
i doing telling me what to do oh I is a
lot of blood okay if if if my girlfriend
was here Oh get out of here if my
girlfriend was here
she's probably hey whoa whoa whoa you're
fast hm hi nope nope no you know I just
try to get close and do that next time
no as I miss nope give me that money
come on Abilio ho ha you're back you're
back
not fast enough oh yeah
good here cut your head off blew your
balls off
oh you got nothing left on you gone gone
give me that gamma dolla bills as I was
trying to say before before they rudely
interrupted me wait he's still alive
just to be sure can't be too careful
with these
yeah hello hello can anybody hear me
nope
my name is Eileen is it just woke up in
here and everybody was gone yeah what
their own here what do they all leave
they hated you I'm going to try and find
someone don't do that here this please
come for me I'm not gonna get any
scratching in the wall yeah you did
hello who's there are you a doctor no
why is everyone wait I know you
you're Harry's the prisoner from the
colony what this one behind me there's
one behind me one behind me God that
lady was talking to me ha ha ha get out
of here get out of here no no it's a bad
monster ha ha so strong yeah good dead
in your goodies all right newborns oh
why are there so many babies on this
ship honestly this is a business ship
right why are people having babies left
and right man Dickie
I mean honestly how many newborns could
there possibly be
this must be the love ship people get
freaky oh hello hi are you doing oh hi
there hi um yeah that that creepy
laughing is really doing it for you hi
oh come on they're just trying to drive
Isaac insane there everyone's killing
themselves right in front of him or
dying right in front he's gonna be
traumatized uh okay saves daisy hmm all
right we're go boring yes override it
all right I see I heard up we've other
ways takes long
sighs love doctor kind chief science
Isaac delay bringing the marker up for
plan there too can i scroll down there
okay to unique to unprecedented cut it
short without proper time to study the
causes and effects finally someone with
some common sense don't rush
bringing the marker up I'm guessing the
marker is what caused all this
whoa whoa whoa that was normal times
early signs of today dr. Khalid the
colony's problems concerned me greatly
uh-huh I have no doubt they are somehow
linked to the discovery of the marker
yeah okay but the exact nature of that
connection is still ago no almost 40% of
the coins experience Orion form of
dementia the obvious symptoms are acute
depression insomnia and hallucination
don't run away use it into violence and
even murder awful indicators hey dad
don't 2003 advised that I bring some of
the affected on board for study dr.
Weller an insight psychiatrist has
reported that his own analysis has been
fruitless and hesitancy reliant dr.
Mercer at this point but I need his
expertise uh-huh we need solutions and
we need them quickly
I think dr. Mercer is the crazy guy so
yeah bad bad calls rustling hi
who's out there
oh no oh it's the morgue
I don't like the Morgan I don't like
morgues
oh why is this morgue so very Morgie uh
they are watching what are they watching
oh why did I pick up is that why did I
pick up his head Oh what is it a back
hey let him go you let him go or I'll
take some drastic action though Oh turn
them black whoa Oh No Oh back off boy
Oh get up not true tonight ha ha ha yeah
yeah yeah yeah here get die Jesus
no get out of here wow you you just
bloom and expand everything went
everywhere okay not the captain's Brig
Oh throw salt blacken laughs Co it's
received and they look good oh I got it
on
I'll start accessing the captain's right
I got it now head to the tram station
and I'll contact you there I'm going to
find out what the hell happened to this
ship
oh that was the captain okay Oh
obviously duh I'm an idiot
power node oh yeah these things cost ten
thousand credits they got it okay um
something else here
no there's something else father's what
do we got
death on ships Abdul deviously
pronounced captain that he's dead yeah
he was dead okay I heard a whisper
family multiple contusions on the arms
hands slight contusions around the
ribcage single prolonged trauma to the
ocular body to his eye finally into the
front wall below rapid neuro trauma
seizure and death okay he died from an
eye injury I didn't know you could die
from an eye injury unlawful death okay
someone murdered him someone murdered
him good I wouldn't be surprised with
murder there's so much you know dead
people on the ship any way I heard
thumping boobie thumping will be
something
all right no one no one made something
good there we go oh wait I came here
before didn't I
what's this power known was it usually
was it worth it the last time I don't
know I don't really judge I guess if a
power node costs 10,000 I think I got
10,000 worth of items in amo yeah tons
amo okay maybe this is worth it BAM
boom more ammo line Rex I don't know
what line Rex are good okay but if there
are schematics in here for new items
then I better go open every single one I
see so I will do that yep all right
actually
it's our way to tell me okay I got zero
nodes any more nodes but anyway I have
to cut it here thank you guys so much
for watching really hope you're enjoying
the series I am I am loving this game is
great besides the controls which I got
used to the game the atmosphere is great
few too many jump scares but atmospheres
great love it alright so thank you so
much for watching and I will see you in
the next part
bye bye